all right we'll get started
hello and welcome to Robin Hanson at the
18th annual fall for the book literary
festival we appreciate your attendance
today our festival runs through
September 30th so for the most
up-to-date information on the festival
including a calendar please visit fall
for the book dot org fall for the book
also touches our community throughout
the year through other programming such
as the writers in Schools program and
new leads writer conference and the
Alumni run feminist literary press
gazing grain just to name a few if you
haven't already done so please remit or
turn off or silence your cellphone's
also help us improve the festival for
next year by filling out a survey the
information we collects helps us improve
the festival from year to year so on
there are also book sales over here to
the right for we can do check and cash
and PayPal cash great on to the event so
dr. Hanson is the author of the book the
age of M work love and life when robots
rule e earth which was published by
Oxford University Press in May of 2016
dr. Hanson is an associate professor of
economics at the Center for study of
public choice here at George Mason
University and a research associate at
the future of the humanity Institute at
Oxford University with nine years
experience as a research programmer at
both Lockheed and NASA so obviously he
has diverse research interests including
but not limited to group insurance
product bands and the bioethics of
health care you can read more about his
work on his blog overcoming bias.com
it'll be worth your time the Financial
Times said of the age of M Robin Hanson
is one of the most original thinkers in
the world and this fascinating account
of our future society is like nothing
you read anywhere else
astonishing stuff please help me welcome
Robin Hanson
[Applause]
I'm going to give a short talk and we'll
have lots of time for questions and I
know there will be lots of questions so
get them ready no reading unless you
really big me this is all of history on
one graph on the x-axis is logarithm of
time to some time in the near future so
it all fits and on the y-axis is the
growth rate of the human economy and of
other things before and you notice it
looks like a staircase so humans started
2 or 1 million years ago and doubled
roughly every quarter million years at a
steady rate and then there was a sudden
transition when the growth rate jumped
up by a factor of more than 50 to having
farmers double roughly every thousand
years that happened throughout 10,000
years ago and then 200 years ago there
was another transition the Industrial
Revolution and then the growth rate
again jumped up in less than a doubling
time to be doubling every 15 years and
that's what it's been doing for the last
few centuries if this trend were to
continue then sometime in the next
century roughly there would be a
five-year period and during that period
there would be a transition to an
economy that instead of doubling every
15 years doubled every month and that
would last for a year or two and then
something else would happen because it
would change again that would be a
straightforward projection of previous
trends here that sounds pretty crazy now
the most dramatic scenario is people
have given for how the economy could in
the society could change a lot our
robots or artificial intelligence
machines and smartest people I was an AI
researcher for nine years from 84 to 93
and I've been in the habit of talking to
people in that field
who have been in the field for at least
20 years and I've been asking them how
far has your field come in the last 20
years as a percentage of the distance to
human level abilities and they usually
tell me five to ten percent of the
distance no noticeable acceleration and
at that rate it would take two to
for centuries for the median field to
reach human level abilities which is
short compared to the distance to the
Roman Empire but not in your immediate
future some people say we're gonna see a
dramatic progress in the future even
though past progress was slow
suddenly it's gonna be much faster
you're gonna go discover a great grand
new theory maybe I'm gonna focus on a
third scenario by which we might achieve
smart robots and it's called brain
emulation the idea is like porting
software today if you have an old
computer that's running software you
like and there's a new computer and you
want to have software like that on the
new computer one approach is to stare at
the old software try to guess how it
works and then write software in the new
computer that acts like how you think
the old one works another approach is to
write what's called an emulator this is
a program on the new computer that makes
the new one look like the old one - the
software if you can do that you could
just move the software straight over run
it there without understanding it
without knowing how it works just move
it so the idea is to do that same thing
port the software that's in the human
brain to do that we need three
technologies to reach high enough levels
none of them are there yet one we need
lots of cheap fast parallel computers -
we need to take individual human brains
and scan them and find spatial and
chemical detail to see which kinds of
cells are we're connected to what with
which parameters and then we need to
have computer models models of the
input-output behavior of each kind of
cell in the brain that says how it takes
signals in changes internal state and
send signals out and if you have good
enough models for all the kinds of cells
in the brain and in a good enough scan
of a particular brain then you can put
together a model of that particular
brain with all those cheap fast parallel
computers and if the models are good
enough and the scan is good enough then
by definition the entire model should be
good enough it should have the same
input-output behavior so you can hook it
up with hands eyes ears mouth and you
could then talk to it it would talk fast
it back it would act the same as the
original would in the same situation and
if you can do that you have what's
called a brain emulation and then
everything could change now I've been
around people talking about this idea
for many decades it's
staple of science fiction and futurism
it's a great College Bowl session topic
when the subject comes up people like to
talk about is it even possible which
technology would make it happen when
would it happen if you could make one
would it be conscious or is it just a
machine if you could make an emulation
of me is it me or is it somebody else
those are all fascinating questions that
I'm going to ignore I think there's a
neglected question that gets set aside
in all those discussions which is what
would actually happen if you had this
technology how does the world change and
there's been very little of that science
fiction sometimes deals with scenarios
with this in it but they just aren't
very realistic think of three kinds of
futurism one way to project the future
is to take trends like decreasing
religiosity increasing leisure
decreasing marriage and try to project
those forward an axe what happens in the
future another kind of futurism is you
look for technologies that might disrupt
trends like self-driving cars or
blockchains
and you ask when with that technology
show up what form would it take how
expensive would it be but a third kind
of futurism is where you take one of
those imagine destructive tectile
disruptive technologies and you say how
would the world change and a lot of the
people who know how to do number two how
to imagine technologies they don't think
number three is possible because like me
when I was an undergraduate in physics
they were taught there is no such thing
as social science nobody knows anything
over there it's all [ __ ]
now I'm a professor of economics by now
and I say it's not we do know things and
I want to try to convince people it is
possible to use social science to think
about the future this is a map of
academia all the different major fields
and how they're connected the links are
co-citation links when the fields talk
to link to each other a lot it turns out
to be a ring which is irrelevant what's
relevant for our purposes is I'm drawing
on all these colored boxes for the
purpose of this book I have an unusually
diverse background that's usually a
penalty in academia but I'm trying to
make a virtue out of it by writing a
book you could only write if you knew a
lot of different fields this will allow
me to take the following approach pick
the low-hanging fruit I'm gonna just go
area by area looking for easy things to
say
straightforward implications of standard
results and when it gets hard I just go
on to the next area I'm gonna do what
theorists do everywhere which is look
for my keys under the lamppost that is I
make simplifying assumptions as
necessary to get concrete results and
I'll explain right now
what those assumptions are this is my
last slide before I start to tell you
about the age of M like an academic I'm
covering my ass trying to tell you about
my methods first of all I'm trying not
to be original or creative other than by
asking this unusual question what would
actually happen if you had brain
emulation
I'm not trying to tell you what you
should like or not like not my job to
make you love it or hate it I'm just
gonna try to tell you what seems likely
to happen if we follow the path of least
resistance I'd be pleased if it sounded
more like a history textbook or like a
business case book and less like a comic
book or a science fiction movie I'm
gonna focus on the robots because that's
where most of the action is although we
will talk about humans I'm not gonna
tell you about the entire history of the
universe for the next trillion years my
ambition is only only I say to tell you
about the next great era after ours that
is as different from our era as ours is
from the foraging and farming eras it
may only last a year or two and then
something else will happen and I'm not
going to talk about that I'm going to
tell you about this era once they're
used to it you are now used to the
industrial era you would know what this
world is like you're comfortable with it
during the early Industrial Revolution
people didn't know where it was going
they were scared it was hard to predict
what they would do then so it's easier
to predict what this world is like once
people used to it so I'm going to focus
after the transition on more of an
equilibrium as an economist I'm going to
use our economist standard best-first
tool which is called supply and demand
supply and demand assumes for whatever
is being sold there's lots of buyers and
sellers and there's not much regulation
and that's what I'm mostly going to
assume it's not saying there should not
be regulation or that there won't be
concentrations of power sometime this is
just our best first tool to start with
and then we go on from there
finally I'm going to assume that these
simulations are opaque and therefore
simple that is you could make the
simulation you could turn it on
but you can't take one person's music
and combine it with somebody else's
Christmas vacation memory you can just
turn them on turn them off erase them
copy them run them fast run them slow
that's it
otherwise it's just a black box so that
means they behave a lot like the
original humans because that's pretty
much all you can do to them
those are my working assumptions and now
I'm gonna tell you about the age of em
as best I guess it some of my results
are true for any world dominated by
robots
robots can be represented as computer
files so robots can be immortal today
houses and cars can be immortal if you
keep repairing them and maintaining them
they could last forever but you don't
always so just because they could be
immortal doesn't mean they are
electronic files can be sent across the
world at the speed of light therefore
robots can travel across the world at
the speed of light because they can be
represented as computer files you are
afraid that if you kill nature you will
die it's a reasonable fear robots
however know that if they are made in
factories that have stuck tup up in
mines and they accidentally kill nature
they do not die there are therefore less
afraid of killing nature you can make
copies of files and this has enormous
implications
first of all wages quickly fall to
subsistence levels that is the
competition from all these copies who
can be very easily made pushes wages
down to the cost of making and renting
new hardware which is much less than
usual human wages or even than human
subsistence wages will talk about humans
in a moment because you can copy so
quickly the economy can grow much faster
in fact standard economic theory says
that if you can make substitutes for
human workers in factories just as fast
as you can make ordinary things we make
today in factories the economy can
double every month that's not crazy it's
just a straightforward implication a
standard economic growth theory if it
takes a year to get to Mars and the
economy doubles every month
profit-seeking ventures will just not
bother it's way too long a delay so
during the age of M which may only
the year - they won't bother with things
in space and not even so much with
things far away on earth now humans must
retire the Amma's will be all
concentrated in a small number of
densities so humans can have the rest of
the earth but humans will be out
competed for their jobs by the
emulations and so collectively humans
all lose their ability to earn wages
however humans also collectively own
this entire world they own all the
factories all the real estate all the
patents all the land so if the economy
doubles every month their wealth doubles
every month humans get rich very fast
collectively but whether any one
individual human does ok depends on them
whether they have sufficient assets
insurance or sharing arrangements my
confident prediction is that since that
is varied enormous Lee in the past
across time and place it will vary again
in the future some places will in fact
have sufficient insurance and sharing
arrangements and others won't tada
emulations start out as human so their
mental and psychological characteristics
are within the human range but they're
not typical humans the competitive
emulation economy selects the few most
productive humans and makes billions of
copies of those so this means the
typical emulation is not in the middle
of the distribution if we thinking about
characteristics that make them more
productive like smart or hardworking
they're off on the end they are elite
probably most emulations are copies of
the few hundred most productive humans
that makes emulations as elite as
typical billionaires head of state Nobel
Prize winners Olympic gold medalists the
typical emulation is that good and they
know it they may look back over on
humans with nostalgia and gratitude but
maybe not so much respect which is if
you think about it how you think about
your ancestors but they have all the
more reason to think so we know a lot of
things that vary and correlate with
who's more productive in our society so
I can just use those things to predict
typical features of emulations they're
more conscientious they're workaholic
they're near a peak age of productivity
whatever that is for us it's like 40 or
50 there probably get up in the morning
they're married even religious
because these are all things that
correlate with being more productive in
our society most jobs in an advanced
economy are desk jobs and there's no
point in putting an M at a little
mechanical desk you might as well let
them stay in virtual reality because
they're already on a computer and it's
really cheap to give them a luxurious
virtual reality compared to just the
cost of running their brain so they have
luxurious beautiful environments in
virtual reality where they work most of
them work and all of them leisure they
never need hunger pain disease grime
their bodies are always beautiful always
look young it's a great world except
notice these are all desks they are
working most of the time they are
hard-working competitive emulations some
of you when you're young you may have
looked around you and thought I seem to
be weird I wonder if I'm from another
planet
wonder if someday I'll meet other people
from my planet and then they'll be my
like me and then we'll get along well
for amaz this is really true because
remember most of them are copies of the
few hundred most productive humans and
so for each one there may be billions of
other emulations who were all came from
the same original human so they have
more in common with them than you even
might have with your identical twin so
that's becomes a new unit of social
organization that they can use for law
and politics and finance and that allows
them to get more things done probably
the most traumatic thing that ever
happened to the human race so far
was the transition from foraging to
farming foragers were in rough
equilibrium with their environment when
they did what felt natural it was
usually the right thing to do but when
farming became possible it was only
possible because humans had a plastic
enough kind of culture that culture
could change and tell people that a new
kind of attitude and value was the kind
that was right for them and so farming
culture cranked up religious pressures
and conformity pressures to create a
whole new set of values of the farming
world farmers had a lot more inequality
and domination and war and lack of
travel more work etc all things that
foragers didn't like but farmers got
used to them that cultural pressure that
held farming in place weakened as we got
rich in the last few hundred years in
the last few hundred years as we
rich it just feels less compelling to go
to these rates in the old farming
culture if a young woman was told if you
have a child out of wedlock you and your
child may starve that was a credible
threat today when you're rich the
society tells you that and you go yeah I
can I could I would survive I do okay
and so the cultural pressures that turn
foragers and the farmers feel less
weakened so we've had forager trends in
the last few centuries this explains
changes in fertility increased democracy
decreased slavery increased leisure
increase already increased travel a
whole bunch of trends over the last few
centuries can be understood in terms of
us going back to forge your ways because
that feels more natural and the threats
that made us into farmers feel less
compelling because we're rich emulations
however are not rich because they go
back to more subsistence income and
because their culture needs them to act
in ways that are not natural to foragers
they probably go back to farming style
culture in many ways they probably
increase the pressures of religion and
conformity and other things in order to
get them to act in the new styles of
ways the humans who are rich capitalist
on the side they probably stay in a
forager culture this is your life simple
you start and then you end this is the
life of an emulation who every day when
they're ready for work they split off a
short term small number of copies each
of whom do a short term task and then
end they maybe they'll stand in line at
the DMV these short-term copies they are
all work the main line copy they work
and then they have to pay for leisure to
get ready for the next day but these
other copies they're all work so they
even though they have the disadvantage
of not remembering what they did as well
they are still much more productive and
so this is a very tempting strategy
we'll talk more about it in a minute
this is an opportunistic em they make
more copies of versions of themselves
when those are in more demand they don't
know ahead of time which ones those will
be so it's a chaotic Tree of Life this
is an emulation designer they conceive
of a whole system perhaps an amusement
park and then they break into copies who
then elaborate the design of that all
the way down to doing all the details in
this way a single emulation can conceive
of a much larger more integrated design
that we can today today when we design a
big thing one guy designs it and then
other
people implement this is an emulation
plumber who remembers every day for the
last 20 years they only ever worked two
hours a day a life of leisure every day
when they were ready for work
they made a thousand copies of this
plumber each of whom did a two hour
plumbing job and only one of them went
on to the next day objectively this
Emmett plumber is working over 99% of
the time subjectively they remember a
life of leisure
so emulations can be working very hard
but that doesn't mean they remember it
that way or see it that way we know of
many systems like software which have
the feature that as they adapt to
particular circumstances in context they
become fragile and harder to readapt to
new context this applies not just to
software but also to products and cells
and species today and to the human brain
human brain start out young with what's
called fluid intelligence able to learn
many things but not knowing much and
they end up with what's called
crystallized intelligence knowing a lot
but harder to learn plausibly that's not
just because of biological aging it's
also because of this general feature
that we see in software because of this
emulations probably age and have a
limited career length they may be able
to live forever indefinitely in
retirement but they have to retire after
a certain period perhaps a century or
two of subjective work life after which
they need to be replaced by other copies
who are trained and slightly later ways
so around most emulations they see
younger and older versions of themselves
who live in the same city marry the same
people do the same jobs and so they have
a really good idea where their future is
going and whether it's going to work out
because they have these all these
versions of themselves around again this
is you this could be you if at the
beginning of a party you took a drug
that said meant that the next day or
ever after you would not remember that
party some people have done this
voluntarily they told me now ask
yourself near the end of this party
would you say to yourself I'm about to
die I became a new creature at the
beginning of this party that no one else
will ever remember therefore I'm new and
I'm about to die this is terrible and
I'm gonna fight and destroy things
because I'm really mad
or you could say to yourself I'm going
to continue tomorrow
I just won't remember what I did today
those are both possible attitudes you
could take I'm guessing most of you
would take the second one but they're
both available as possibilities this is
the same structure and this is for an
emulation who splits off a short-term
copy who stands in line at the DMV and
then ends they could think of themselves
as a new creature with a short live
which they hate and they're going to
fight it or they could think of this as
a part of themselves that they won't
remember I predict this is the second
will be their actual attitude not
because it's the correct view just
because humans have enough plasticity to
encompass many possible views and the
cultural greatly reward the second
attitude because it's a competitive
world and this helps in competition now
even if you are okay with ending and not
remembering what you did if people
around you talked to you before and then
you don't seem to remember what they
talked to you about that would frustrate
them so a simple solution is to copy
whole teams of people together
have them work together and then enter
retire together today it's hard to meet
celebrities their time is limited with
emulations however if you want to meet a
celebrity it's easy they just spent off
another copy and then you meet with that
celebrity it's hard to do is to get
celebrities to remember you because this
copy doesn't necessary pass on what they
learned to the mainland copy we can use
this however to an advantage today if
the president says we must invade Iraq
and you say why and they say can't tell
you the state secrets you'll have to
trust me you're in trouble
you don't know whether you can trust
them emulations however can play the
following trick a citizen makes a copy
of themselves who goes into the safe the
president makes a copy who goes into the
safe inside the safe the president can
explain all of their secret reasons and
at the end the entire safe is erased
except one bit comes out the one bit was
was I persuaded the citizen tells their
original version why was or was not
persuaded by this argument and so now
you can find out and believe things even
though they can't know the actual
reasons
in your life today you have three phases
you have a young youth where you train a
middle life for your the most productive
and then a retirement afterwards
emulations have the same three phases
but they can train a few copies and then
make many copies of those trainees so
they can afford to put a lot of
resources into training and then if
they're not rich when they retire
instead of starving to death
they can just retire slow I told your
emulations could run fast or slow and
the cost of running an emulation is
proportional to speed over a wide range
so that means if you run 10 times slower
you cost 10 times less so emulations can
retire at a slow speed that means as
soon as they retire the world around
them suddenly starts speeding up and
they actually care about the stability
of the civilization at that point now
this range over which speed is
proportional to cost probably goes up to
at least a million times human speed or
a down to a billion times slower than
human speed so there's a huge range of
speeds and they probably clump into
classes of speeds that is it makes more
sense like we clump into cities so we
can interact with others they would
slump into the same speed so they could
interact with others at the same speed
and faster emulations our high status in
many ways they embody more wealth they
host meetings they win arguments they
know things first
they are just high status so this is a
class hierarchy and it's an enormous
class hierarchy where those at the top
really have an objective reason for
saying they're better they are able to
just do a lot more because they're
faster down at the bottom of this
hierarchy is mostly retirees and they
are like the ghosts of our literature if
you recall in literature ghosts or
creatures that are all around rarely
able to interact with them sometimes you
could but what's the point because they
don't know much they can't do much and
they aren't really useful allies they're
kind of obsessed with the past their
skills are out of date all you can do is
just you know have a weird conversation
with them if you want so that's what the
retirees in many ways are like a whole
world of ghosts who the ghosts even have
their own ghosts because there are
things even slower than them and that's
the weird world of the Age of em in
terms of different speeds
today we clump into cities because it's
valuable but we aren't all in one big
city because when we double the size of
a city we get 34% more
traffic congestion per person which
limits having big cities however for
emulations they can meet with anybody in
a city in virtual reality without
actually sending themselves or their
brain they can just send the bits that
represent the meeting so they can
interact long distances cheaply which
means they have much less transport or
travel costs which means they can
actually can cram into a small number
perhaps even one big dense cities today
if you are in virtual reality
interacting with anybody on the earth at
human speed the signal delay of getting
Lightspeed there is less than your
reaction time of a tenth of a second so
you don't actually have to know where
they are
when emulations run faster than not
however if they're running sixteen times
faster than human speed then they need
to be within a thousand kilometers so
they can not notice where they are
they're running 256 times faster they
need to be within sixty kilometres et
cetera this puts a limit on how fast
emulations want to go if they go too
fast then they start to having fewer
people that can interact with it easily
however if they run too slow then the
skills they develop early in their
career are quickly irrelevant because
the economy changes too fast so the
sweet spot between this is roughly a
thousand times human speed which is my
guess for how fast emulations run so in
the one or two years of the emulation
era they would experience thousands of
years so there's plenty of time for
cultural change in lots of events to
happen in the M world to the emulations
even if not to the humans outside this
is my last slide many of you I'm really
quite sure are tempted to evaluate this
world and decide whether you like it or
not but think your ancestors from a
thousand years ago would have loved or
hated your world depending on the first
few things they heard about it because
it's so easy to have a fast reaction
your world is just weird to them and
this world is just weird to you so one
way of course is to read my whole book
and understand in a more great detail
but otherwise just pause and try to see
the world in its full complexity before
you make a quick evaluation but these
pluses and minuses will give you some
reminders first remember in virtual
reality no pain hunger grime disease
beautiful bodies they're not that afraid
of death or ending they have a vast
population finds their life worth living
many of you have said I couldn't live in
a small town because there's just not
enough going on there there biggest
cities will be so much bigger than yours
they'd say that about your cities
just not enough going on in your cities
the larger economy can afford to develop
a more fixed cost for art and stories
music etc the world seems were stable to
them these are all pluses perhaps on the
minus sign perhaps they are living at
subsistence wages that is they must work
most of the time to eat now this is how
most of your ancestors ever lived until
a few hundred years ago most L humans
lived near subsistence wages and pretty
much all animals have so it's not a
hypothetical scenario it's the standard
scenario in history they work long hours
they often make short-term copies that
ends there's more inequality of various
sorts in this world the larger more
bureaucratic firms they're perhaps less
nature less space travel more religion
less democracy this is the age of em as
best I guess it again not my job to make
you love it or hate it just to tell you
roughly what I'd guess if you do nothing
if you really want to change it you are
welcome to try this is the age of M and
now I'm sure you have many questions and
comments to discuss
you say you suggested that in this world
humans are the owner owner owner class
right they start out as being the
richest yes and I mean I guess I don't
understand why because the robot seemed
to have a complicated subjectivity they
would tolerate that state of affairs
well today and for a long time we have
seen high levels of ownership inequality
of capital it's just been one of the
features of the world for a long time
clearly it's existed and been stable for
a long time so I think it could continue
to exist in be stable high levels of the
most impressive humans yes so now
there's two kinds of success in this
world to think about so mostly when we
think about inequality and envy we think
about some individuals being richer than
other individuals but success in this
world is that some humans or an atom's
have more descendants than others
each individual has descended here
typically has about the same personal
income there's very little variance in
the in the wages that these M's make the
variation is who has how many
descendants of course there's also
variation in who owns capital but that's
the kind of variation that we already
have now so the humans are the rich
capitalists mostly initially but then
the emulations start to have more of the
capital because we already know that
absentee owners get lower rates of
return than in combination over newer
managers since the emulations are going
to be combination owner managers they
will get higher rates of return on their
investment and so slowly they will have
a larger fraction of the wealth but that
will take some time presumably the
humans will also just lose out because
they are so clueless of this world and
outside they will just be exploited and
mismanaged their investments and spend
too much and so presumably they would
lose their wealth faster but there's
still a long time where humans are used
their wealth now we already have lots of
rich retirees in our world and we could
say to ourselves one of those rich
retirees doing for us let's kill them
and take their stuff it's something we
could say but we don't so that sets a
precedent perhaps for a while at least
the humans could be rich retirees let
the MS don't kill them and take their
stuff because that threatens the
stability of this similar their society
just like killing our retirees and
taking their stuff with the strenght and
stability of our society
back there you're good okay let's take
your plumber example and you had a bunch
of plumbers working two hours a day and
then one of them survives so the first
question is how do you decide which one
survives second your scenario was
trained work with tire you can't learn
everything in a training period you have
to learn on the job sure how does that
one surviving plumber consolidate the
information from the hundred other jobs
that he as plumber we're doing so that
he can continue to learn and become a
better plumber say worth more whatever
and related to that humans do need some
downtime and presumably emulations would
need downtime as well so I'm not in
other than numbers they wouldn't
necessarily work all the time so that's
why I describe them as having a break at
the end of the workday which I describe
as you know being expensive which is why
it's tempting to not have all of the
copies continue on to the next day so
there's a trade-off in productivity
these spurt copies you know compared to
someone who works 12 hours a day and
then takes 12 hours to rest these side
copies they are twice that they are half
as cost per hour which is a huge
temptation now you also don't learn as
much from them but that can be worth the
factor of two for some so you have
enough experience that the main line
copy knows enough to do their job well
and then you are willing to pay for
having these other side copies who are
much cheaper and so you make the right
trade-off between learning as much as
you need to do to your job well and
trying to do it as cheaply as possible
by only making as many learning versions
as you need that's how the EM economy
would make that choice they would
definitely have leisure in terms of
which ones continue uh
this is up to them of course now you ask
yourself what would you do right because
you are you are their first copy there
you decide what happens to the next day
for example how do you want it to go if
you can't manage to do this and actually
when you're these copies actually do
their job then you aren't a very good
candidate for this world this world is
full of people who find a way
do this scenario and find a way that
it's okay with them and probably the
simplest way is they it's random which
one goes on to the next day or at least
random enough that while all of them
think they have a chance and they
remember of course a long history where
they were the one who was picked because
exactly so they can be irrationally i
ballistic about it they're all
equivalent why shouldn't it be me
instead of you why wouldn't that just
create you ever gone to Vegas thrown
some dice why should it be you that when
somebody else right it's random huh I
refused to die well could not
productively be completed by people who
only had a couple hours of memory of
those jobs will cost more so that is in
the world of tasks see even today you
know there's some jobs that can be
automated and then once we find a job
that can be automated we're willing to
do that a lot more because it's a lot
cheaper for jobs that are more expensive
we do them less because they're
expensive so which jobs are more
expensive in this world changes somewhat
so in this world you know engineers make
the same as janitors pretty much all
professions make the same wages in this
world which is quite different than our
world so in this world they choose fewer
lawyers and more janitors because more
generous excuse me if you were because
all the things that are expensive in our
world get really cheap in there all all
the highest per faying professions in
our world that today we don't do as much
of because they're expensive the people
who do them charge a lot here they're
all just as cheap as any other job so
you do the more of them exactly you're
just will yourself out of existence
so just to be clear there's two options
when a productive cycle is over one is
simply a ratio another is retirement and
if you retire at 1,000 the speed it only
costs 1,000 to as much so if you're at
all slightly squeamish about being
erased fine just retire slow it's very
cheap
we'll do that for you some emulations
will be okay with just erasing and then
they will do that those who are not they
will retire slow like socially the
implication of having one of your spurs
murder the predecessor like because you
say that it's random right they or it
could be rent I will say it doesn't have
to be a central choice each and we can
decide this for themselves you can
figure out what works for you in terms
of which copies you make what they do
and how you've prune it back if you're
not okay with any process then you're at
a competitive disadvantage those who
figure out some way to be okay with it
some way to manage it they continue on
and there could be a diversity of ways
they do it it doesn't all have to be one
way so whatever works for them but I
just do predict some people will find a
way to do it some people will be okay
with it in this world will be full of
people like that just because I already
know you guys are mostly okay with the
not remembering the party thing you're
willing to see yourself at the party
last week who you don't remember as you
and at the party you're willing to see
that future version is you and that's
pretty much the same structure so I
predict some people will be okay with it
other people aren't then they aren't
here so it's just a straight forward
selection argument and again it's not my
job to make you like the world just to
tell you what it's like
a candidate for M to make up an
emulation with the brain that they copy
have to be a deceased person or would
have you could just copy anyone's brain
so technology would change over time at
the very beginning most likely the
effective scanning technology is
destructive that is you would destroy a
brain in the process of reading all its
details in order to become an emulation
so at that early period it's quite a
choice you are choosing between
continuing a human life or becoming an
emulation and worse very quickly the
emulation world will mostly want
children from humans as opposed to
adults and so you'd have the image of
the rich emulation world or the capital
that the large wealthy powers in the
emulation world approaching human adults
who have promising human children saying
could we destructively scan your child
so that they have a chance to be trained
and become a successful emulation that
would has a lot of potential for drama
and conflict but I still predict some of
them will do it and their world will be
full of descendants of those children
one way or the other agents their
environment is a virtual world or is it
better to think of it as ends are when
they're created they are these agents in
a virtual world and then when they need
to interact with our world they download
themselves to a bottle is there I would
think of it like we are people who get
into cars sometimes when we need to be
in cars when we need a car we get in the
car and then we're a person driving a
car and when we don't need a car we get
out of the car and we're not in the car
anymore
so the emulations would get into a
physical body as appropriate for
whatever tasks are needed they could
switch on a minute-by-minute basis if
they wanted to you know because those
who are doing physical tasks like
managing a factory or driving a truck or
you know whatever it is they would need
a body appropriate for that task but
only while they're doing the task that
the body needs and then the body could
be any sort of body that was appropriate
for the task it wouldn't have to look
very human and an emulation in the
virtual reality of course they could
make their bodies look like whatever
they want but they would probably still
make them mostly human looking I guess
but I don't know
yes questions and if so does once
if you make many copies of the same
original brain all of those brains have
the same feelings that I'm of
so by definition an emulation of a brain
is capable of all the same processes
that the original brain is which
includes learning and remembering and
changing moods so when you scan the
original brain it has some initial state
that we will let it what it had for
breakfast its mood at that moment what
it remembers from the last day and when
you turn on the MS emulation it starts
in that state remembering those things
but if it has a few days or a few years
experience it becomes something else it
becomes a new creature who has the new
set of experiences so by assumption
these have all the same emotions and
emotional reactions in the same moods
because they are emulations of the same
original that by definition an emulation
of the original does the same thing in
the same situation so the reason why an
emulation becomes different later is
because it's had a different life it's
lived in a different world and because
of that different world it becomes
something different but it's still
within the human range of experience you
can think about what a human would do in
these circumstances and that's helpful
in thinking about what the emulations
would do that makes sense to be
completely okay with their station in
life for an eternity it's that legacy
scan what would a legacy scan be like
you decide not to kill ghosts your
ghosts so I told you that the low end of
the speed range probably goes down to
one billionth that's because that's
roughly the speed where the cost of
running a human speed emulation is is
basically 1 billion the cost of saving
an archived copy so archive copies of
emulations are actually really cheap you
can at 1% of the cost of five minutes
experience you can spin off a copy an
archived copy every 5 minutes so they
just have a lot of our kyv copies
sitting around each archived copy
doesn't necessarily expect it will ever
be revived it's available to be revived
but it doesn't have a good reason to
expect it will be so when a copy is made
of you unless you were told to expect
something you just remember being who
you were at the time the copy was made
know most most archived copies are still
there static they're just a frozen state
and they're available to be run again if
you want to turn it on and run it now
running very slow ends up being like in
the limit running very slow is like not
running at all right so very the very
slow retirees are somewhat in an
intermediate state where they can
experience the world but it's going so
fast but at least they don't have to be
scared they're ending but the world
world is growing so fast they do have to
worry about whether the civilization is
stable on the timescale
there's an objective means of deciding
who is better than who and society based
off of speed so if I'm competitive and I
have legacy copies of myself sitting in
this kind of stasis even though they're
running am I am i expected it as a
legacy to just be okay with being
objectively worse forever this is not a
centralised world so those of you may
not know I'm an economist using
economics and one basic feature of
economics many people don't realize is
we analyze worlds where nobody's in
charge nobody runs the world there are
lots of separate powers each of whom run
their own part of it and they get to
choose how they run it there's a
competition that puts pressure on them
to not do things too far away from what
is the more efficient but they can do
things in a variety of different ways so
inside your clan you can have whatever
rules you want to have about deciding
which copies you revive when and when
you turn them off and what you do with
them it's up to you but you're under
pressure like a firm or you know would
be to figure out an efficient way to do
this so just like today in a firm
there's a process for deciding who does
which jobs that process has some people
doing more pleasant jobs than others
some people get paid more than others
there's various processes at different
firms that decide that but pretty much
everybody sorts themselves into some
local world where those decisions get
made and the emulations would again sort
themselves into some world where these
decisions get made somehow and I'm
trying to analyze the netic consequences
of these decisions and not predict
exactly who get does what where
and the Reviva assuming the main topic
gets damaged when they awaken when
because change changes had Alba sorry
trends had already changed so much would
they realize that you know they're
already less effective now and would
they be able to still do anything
would they be anywhere near as valued so
when you when you have a range of copies
available in archives and you're
wondering which one is most appropriate
for some tasks you have a number of
considerations one is that whoever was
just doing that task a moment ago is
probably a good candidate so you're
tempted to just keep on with whoever was
doing it but you have some other options
if that old one seems to be getting
older and frail and fragile maybe you're
thinking of replacing it with a younger
version and then you'll have to make the
cost which is there'll be a transition
cost of this younger version isn't as
familiar with this context and maybe
they aren't up on the latest skills but
they're younger and more flexible and so
you're willing to pay that cost of
paying for the transition to have
somebody else swap into the role this is
how we do it on jobs today and most
firms somebody's doing a job but we
don't always have the same person do the
same job sometimes we swap in somebody
else to do a job and sometimes that's
because we want to have a younger person
come in who learn some new ways and has
some flexibility to take over a swap so
it's the same sort of thing you have a
range of options and you're choosing
which ones seem to be best suited for
the role living in basically their own
virtual reality and unaware that they
are a copy
No that is many of you have seen movies
of no humans and other creatures in
virtual realities and of course a
favorite story and virtuality is
somebody's in the virtuality but they
don't know it's a virtual reality it's a
simulation or or they once knew but they
don't care anymore because they're in
this movie yes fantastic
created world for them so yes emulations
could live in fantastic created worlds
for them but who's going to pay for it
is the key question
it's a worldís assistants wages where
most people need to work most of the
time to just exist that is they need a
spot on the computer hardware there
there's the cities are huge racks of
computer hardware they need to rent a
slot in that computer hardware to exist
that means they need to pay for that
rental that need to pay for the hardware
the energy the cooling the structural
support communication repair taxes they
need an income to pay for all that stuff
and they in equilibrium most of them
need to be working most of the time to
pay for that now on their free time when
they have a limited free time they can
do whatever they want in strange rocha
realities but on work and when they're
socializing with colleagues and friends
they need to be in the same virtual
reality as them because that's how work
in friendship works so most of the time
most of them are in shared virtual
realities with others which can be
beautiful and comfortable but they have
to compromise on the details of those
virtuality x' because they can't all be
in charge because they share them you
don't but you have to ask yourself if
this were actually the world this would
be a very expensive simulation right all
of you people are just not very useful
for doing what this world needs at the
moment so they're paying for all of you
to run your minds here and yet what what
value are they getting for me is just so
not a very plausible scenario that they
would be running you in the situation to
get these things done now in a big
enough world there's some strange rich
person who wants to run some strange
thing maybe you're one of them
but how many of those could there be is
the question yes
virtual reality do you think that a
detailed graphic virtual reality would
be less expensive significantly less
expensive than a sophisticated program
running an emulated human brain because
I I don't know if it's a trivial
question whether the sort of sounds
audio-visual virtual reality where
people socialize in the manner that
currently find productive and enjoyable
would necessarily be and a much much
much easier computer program than the
sophisticated human brain that's that
performs tasks and has opinions I don't
know if that is certain do you think it
would being something that you think we
can say that if you want to simulate a
world like we see here in enough detail
that even an expert using expert
materials and tests couldn't tell the
difference that could be very expensive
on the other hand we've seen people
function in Second Life and virtual
realities and video games which are the
cost of which is vastly less than the
cost of running a brain and they seem to
function okay and be able to function
and even enjoy themselves in virtual
environments that have enormous ly less
computing cost so it definitely looks
like people could be okay functioning in
costs that virtual realities that cost
much less than to rent a brain because
again we are now not able to run a brain
the brains given our current computing
power our brains are really enormous the
expensive yet all of you have video
games on running on tiny hardware that
actually produced ok environments so it
looks like it's really quite easy
security aspects because everything is
you know on computers
virtual world and what a human be able
or even another and be able to create
like a virus or some type of I guess
just something that could fundamentally
change other ENS to corrupt their what
makes them being or like change their
morality on a fundamental level so in
economics when we do supplying to men
our usual first assumption of course is
that property rights are preserved and
that theft and war doesn't happen but of
course we are quickly able to move past
that initial assumption to model and
understand worlds where theft is
possible and war does happen in the
world we live in now we have a modest
degree of theft and a modest degree of
war and that costs us a few percentages
of percentage points of the economy but
it's a relatively small correction the
emulation world looks like it's capable
of having enough protection of property
rights and things such that they could
also only have to pay a few percentage
points of their economy to keep to keep
most things safe and to suffer sometimes
when things don't I would say that again
they don't care that much about ending
copies when there's lots of other closed
copies by but one thing they will really
hate is mine theft so if you're say
trying to travel long distance that
somebody grabs a copy of that brain as
it goes along they can do things bad to
you having stolen a copy of you they
could torture this copy to gain secrets
they could figure out how to treat this
copy to convince you of things they
could make this copy compete with you in
the market and take away your wealth
stolen copies of you are bad things in
this world will dislike stolen copies
and they will work much harder to
prevent theft really of copies of brains
than they would use this would be a
great moral outrage to them death is
less of an issue than theft
why did you change your mind about while
you were writing the book and living in
the world of M I'm in other words what
assumptions did you have going in that
you didn't have going out I guess I
didn't fully appreciate how weird things
would be that is the world is a very
large place so basically I I tried to
describe an entire civilization so I
would have finished I would have had a
book half the size and being done half
as long if the publisher had been ready
for me because they took a long time to
be ready for me I just kept working and
adding things to it and it ended up
adding a lot and so I just kept going
over other areas saying well what what
would you know this area say about this
world and then ended up with a lot and
in total when you look at it all it's
really just a lot in the sense that you
know the world we live in is a
complicated place and your world is
really just strange for your distant
ancestors you don't really quite
appreciate just how strange your world
is it has so many moving parts of so
many little things that are different
because of lots of little reasons you
understand and to it but they wouldn't
get so when I really try to think about
a different world in great detail and
work out as many details as I can that
the most dramatic thing is wow there's
just a lot of things that can change and
the net effect of that is just a whole
strange different world and our first
reaction when we hear about a strange
different world which is of course what
fiction writers like yourself understand
which is they need to give readers clues
right ahead whether they're supposed to
like or hate the world and what they're
supposed to like or hate about it
because that's what readers are looking
for a novel but a real strange world
just you're kind of at a loss because
you don't know whether you're supposed
to like or hate it because it's just
strange and even when you've immersed
yourself in a lot you just realize well
I sort of see this world from a lot of
different views as if I was traveler and
had reported on but since I haven't
lived there for years I still don't know
if I'd love her in her hate it
because it's just weird it's just full
of weird detail that's I guess what you
should really expect if you really
understood how different the pasta was
you should really expect the future to
be quite different in a ways that it's
hard to intuit just a world of lots of
little changes that add up to a strange
different world let me talk about this
first bullet under the plus no pain
hunger grad disease aged bodies that's
going to be true for the EMS what about
the 20 billion 30 billion people who are
out there not doing anything right
they'll still have say childbirth which
is painful I have been told they'll
still age they'll die they'll get
Alzheimer's whatever so I don't really
understand that first this is about the
emulations so if you were thinking about
valuating in this world basically when
this world shows up you add this world
to all the humans but in for the year or
two the same age event exists the number
of humans doesn't change much it can't
change much in a year or two and human
culture can't change much in a year or
two so basically you have a snapshot of
the human world when this starts
suddenly they all retire suddenly they
get rich but pretty much no other
changes they can't have very many babies
they can't do very many things because
there's just not enough time
so for humans it's really much the same
now you're thinking what if we add on
this human world this whole world of
Em's do I like or not this added part of
the world what what do I think of that
so that's what you may be evaluating
because basically the humans there are
some changes the humans they lose their
jobs and they you know if they share
sufficiently they can be comfortable and
rich but that's pretty much all there is
to say about the humans because there's
not enough time for things to happen to
them
the humans should be worried about what
happens next of course and if you were a
human there you should be worried about
what happens next and I'm not telling
you what happens next and that's just
the way it goes and that's just a basic
feature of the world changing fast
the faster the future changes the more
you should expect that rapidly changing
future to intrude on your life and make
you unable to tell what's going to
happen fast change does that happier
because they'll be able to retire but
that will only happen if people like
share or insure themselves properly so
what are the rules that we have to write
to share properly is that minimum basic
income and should be rewriting those
rules now because is it possible to
predict when the age of M will happen so
as with insurance of all sorts it's best
if you think a problem might happen to
just buy the insurance and not try to
predict exactly when it's gonna happen
and make sure you buy it just before the
problem right a better just to have by
the insurance ahead of time so yes if
this problem is not plausibly gonna
happen soon on the other hand when it
does happen it could happen pretty fast
I really don't recommend that you try to
wait until you see clear signs because
by then it might be too late
so sure set yourself up now to the
extent you can insurance and sharing can
happen at all possible scales you could
have a global treaty where we with the
whole world make some agreement that
seems unlikely and you and your family
you and your siblings in your you know a
spouse you can also share at a very
local level you can just do things
personally by having a contract with an
insurance company or an investment make
choosing your investments differently so
there's a wide range of options you have
available to yourself to acquire assets
insurance or sharing arrangements pursue
them all look figure out which ones look
you know easiest and most effective and
do those I don't have any strong
argument about why you should do any one
thing but I don't think you should
fixate on any one option as the option
you should look at whatever you can do
so sure you can convince the government
to do something great but don't count on
that probably if you can do something
inside your family yourself maybe you
should just do that too and you know
protect yourself and your family
yourself if you can rather than relying
on other people
protect you well that seems the most
straightforward thing to do most of you
probably can and you should be religious
or ritualistic because technically for
them there's no real reason it just
doesn't seem like there would be a
reason for it
well we have a standard story in social
science about why religion arose
religion is different than spirituality
spiritual for Jers had spirituality but
it took farmers to really have religion
religion has these powerful central
moralizing God with a lot of rules and a
lot of a lot of dislike for people
breaking the rules which is somewhat
different than traditional spirituality
and this sort of traditional religion
was very effective seems to have been a
very effective at getting farmers to
follow the new cultural norms that the
farming world had there's actually
correlations between places when they
started farming and their attitudes to
religion and things like that
so it looks like religion has this story
what it was there for rituals are part
of the binding to religion there are
many rituals outside a religion ritual
is uh but with ritual is a thing
religions use religions use many other
ways to make people feel bound to their
group to follow the norms etc and the
world of Em's has need of these in the
sense that they as I'm pointing out they
need they have a lot of behaviors that
is appropriate in this world that don't
come natural to forges they will need to
act in new ways and religion and other
sorts of cultural pressures are
available as resources to this world to
get them to do that and again he's even
even today there's a correlation people
who are more religious tend to earn more
today straightforward correlation and so
it looks like even today religions are
helpful in getting people to be more
productive so that seems to protect here
in the back yes assuming the first M
they may be really expensive or there's
not a whole lot of processing power
right what do you think are the first
jobs they'll take and do you think there
are any jobs that wouldn't be suitable
for ends the second one is more easy if
you are a rich human and you want a real
human servant to serve you dinner then
why you may we willing to pay for a real
human to serve you dinner because you're
rich enough and you want it and you're
just going to get so clearly when there
is a demand for a human to do the job
because it's a human doing the job
somebody wants to be sure even a
certified making sure it doesn't just
look like a human it really is a human
why then humans could do those jobs
that's gonna be a pretty limited range
of jobs because these emulations really
can do pretty much anything a human can
except be a real human now for the very
beginning the very first emulations you
know you've spent billions of dollars
making this first emulation you've got
some hardware expensive to run but you
can run it what are you looking for
you're looking for people at the top of
their profession today who the world is
willing to pay law for there's a lot of
people willing to pay for that so now if
the scan is the main cost then you'll
want to scan somebody who room there's a
lot of demand the scans not so expensive
you're focused on the individual jobs
that are expensive so CEOs for example
are often paid a lot if the scan is
cheap but the running the emulation is
lot maybe you'll take the very best CEOs
and make thousands of copies of those
CEOs is though a pretty small job market
if you want lawyers say hey there's a
lot more of those software engineers so
you can imagine take the very best
software engineer the very best lawyer
and making lots and lots of copies of
those I'm making a lot of money right at
the very beginning but as I said the
very beginning you want the people who
are best in the current human world but
very quickly the world changes and so
you want younger people who are more
flexible able to adapt to become learn
the new ways in which case the emulation
world quickly looks for younger human
children the scan and if that's
descriptive again you have the problem
of destructively scanning human children
to make productive emulation workers
which a dramatic story
put out three assumptions of what's
needed to have effective emulations have
you given much thought to the status of
each of those sciences or crafts like
the parallel cheap route processing is
is in the near future but the others may
not
what's your projection on the
actualization of those three assumptions
so I said there are three technologies
required fast cheap computers brain
scans and brain cell modeling these are
really very different sized industries
amoment computers is a huge industry
that has a huge momentum there's very
little anybody could do to influence
that based on emulations however brain
cell modeling is a tiny area of academia
and so there's a lot more scope there
for putting more effort in if you wanted
to speed it up presumably when people
start to think this is possible soon
they would put huge amounts of money
into speeding up whatever areas are
almost ready but they'd wait until they
were almost ready at the moment you know
brain cell modeling is a long way off
scanning is probably even it's probably
one of the closest we're actually pretty
doing pretty well with brain scans so
but brain cell modeling is hard to
predict that is with scans it's just
like you know can you do it faster can
you do a finer resolution you can track
it you can just project it forwards just
a matter of scaling the effort similarly
with computers with modeling you don't
really know when you're done until
you're done you know so you could have
more unexpected jumps in progress where
you thought it was a long way off and
then finally all of a sudden boom you're
done and so that's why it's harder to
predict the brain scale modeling which
might make it the last thing to be ready
or that or first anyway what happens so
the transition happens differently
depending on which of these technologies
is the last one ready if the last
technology ready is very widely
available this becomes a very
distributed very smooth transition if
it's very steady and anticipated it
becomes a steady anticipated transition
if the last technology to be ready is in
hard to anticipate technology that's
very concentrated or very random then
you can end up with very random suddenly
it happens people didn't expect it it's
only a very small group that has access
to it that sort of thing you have more
unequal transition if it's a more
unequal technology that ends up pushing
you over the line compared to other
kinds of artificial intelligence this is
more of a threshold technology so with
ordinary AI we slowly get better we
displace more jobs and it's just this
long slow wave in the economy with an
emulation until you have a whole
emulation working you don't have much of
anything that's useful and so there's a
point in time where you actually can do
an emulation and now all of a sudden you
can do a lot and so that creates the
possibility of a more sudden hard to
anticipate and more disruptive
transition when it's finally shows up
what's our time here yeah I mean when
are we supposed to be done does anybody
know does anybody have another question
or if not I will thank you I have a few
copies for sale and thank you for coming
[Applause]